isabell mad no Vivian pull in a nose
concern oh nervously small good
afternoon
so today the Commission and the European
Investment Fund have launched the
first-ever equity funding program for
the --use yes blue economy sector the
blue invest fund was announced this
morning that the blue invest a
conference in Brussels and what is it
it's a seventy-five million equity
investment fund which would provide
financing to underlying equity funds the
target projects and companies in the
innovative blue economy what do we see
as the innovative blue economy its
economic activities related to ocean
seas and coasts ranging from companies
in the marine environment to land based
businesses producing goods or services
that contribute to the maritime economy
and of course this blue economy sector
can play an important role in the
transformation of our society and
economy to the carbon neutrality by 2050
the objective that we've announced in
the Green Deal in December as well as at
the European Council conclusions the
blue invest fund is backed by the
European fund for strategic investments
the financial pillar of the investment
plan for Europe and you will have more
information in our press release any
questions to Vivian on this announcement
no yes
yes you see a popular comunicaciones
Killian live yes it's at the program la
de la marche programa de la capacity
they met the cote de la commissioner
panel from damage despond during our
open source and cancer miyeon the hope
makes a sudden economy blue darle
economy move in the sense that we don't
settle for novices most give a year cola
proceed ABI achieve more doctor jnana
federal v alexis was intense media
doctor question no so finally let me
welcome the visitors that we have with
us here today a group of journalists
from Mexico Colombia Bolivia and
Argentina if I'm not mistaken when we
need us I'll stay and with that we are
ready to take your questions away